[Applause]
which for comic-con is cosplaying as
movies so everyone's eating movies right
now hater tots
[Applause]
uh i myself am a big fan of the vegan
cheese steak which is absolutely amazing
and i invented a sandwich called the
pillow pants yes
um don't wait for a [ __ ] restaurant
to let you name a sandwich create a
restaurant name whatever the [ __ ] you
want kids
[Applause]
um we're doing a streaming daily we did
a show last night uh
today and tomorrow we're doing uh quick
one-hour updates in case anything cool
has happened at the con and stuff uh has
anything cool happened at the con so far
well
[Music]
right there [ __ ] that lady is happy
yeah oh my god what connor are you at i
want to go there
uh yeah i went today i went onto the
floor i went to a [ __ ] panel like i
used to do when i was a normal person
really yeah i just interacted with the
normies i just
it's that thing where like you know in
the olden days the the royalty used to
slum it going into the bazaar to see
what it's like to for the average person
to try to buy a date with a cloak and
[ __ ] throw some dirt in your face and
walk the streets and [ __ ] that's exactly
what i did
i uh joined us plebes i left my cloak in
the uber on my way over
i i went to the marvel studios animation
panel today
man now where were they where'd they do
it that was in the big ballroom 20.
[ __ ] a and you had to wait in line
for that we have a goddamn show
where we talk about marvel all the time
nobody was like you [ __ ] fat man
beyond get the [ __ ] in here no and i'm
also not that guy to be like excuse me
excuse me fat man beyond please i'd like
to go to the head of well neither am i
but i dress the part you know i can walk
around like style and bob going i hope
this gets me invited in yeah i need to
you know i was thinking today at one
point i was busting through the hotel
[ __ ] lobby and i moved very quick for
a larger person instead uh people say
that all the time like god damn you're
fast in the way that like you shouldn't
be but like i am i move very briskly and
if you catch me i'll totally take a
picture and [ __ ] but i'm like a
leprechaun you got to catch me first oh
i've tried to keep up with you at an
airport and it is [ __ ] rough yeah
it's it's i tend to go very [ __ ]
because what they don't tell you is when
you're a heavy person every day is leg
day
and then if you lose that weight you're
a [ __ ] rocket [ __ ] the uh my wife is
always fond of talking about what she
refers to as my quote unquote guns and
naturally they're not up here it's my
calves she spends a lot of time in life
around me and she's like god damn your
calves are [ __ ] toned which always i
hear the comment behind the comment
which is like why can't you tone the
rest
but she don't care she's a big fan and
[ __ ] however as i was briskly going
through the hotel lobby
um i had this like sense of gratitude
and thanks for the fact that
a lot of people come to comic con they
like dress up like they pick up somebody
in their cosplay i literally get to
cosplay myself
like i just put on a silent bob coat
backwards hat if i could go through and
three times today people were like
that's the best son of a bob here
and i felt really proud of that you know
because i don't know if they knew who i
was or not but i agree with them i am
the best silent bob here
the uh
this however may be the second best
style silent bob here ladies and
gentlemen the good folks at big shots
are making these pillows that look pull
the j one over
and they're big they sent one in my
house look at you working it like a
puppet well done we could do a whole
show
[Music]
you know what i'll do the writing [ __ ]
off
um they sent me big ones like this they
got like a buddy christ as well and they
got a weed a wee bag of weed and stuff
but don't they look like the wrestling
buddy pillows from back in the day
when they showed me like we're gonna we
want to make these i was like [ __ ] yeah
and my kid sought a prototype and she my
kid is real cringed about everything i
do
that has my face on it so anytime i wear
a shirt with my face on it she's like oh
my god that's so embarrassing i was like
i can't expect a muffin to buy a shirt
with my face on it if i'm not willing to
wear it first here's a pair of jane
silent bob underwear for you to wear
and she turned that down so [ __ ]
hardcore she's like i don't wear you on
this part of my body why the [ __ ] would
i wear you down there and [ __ ]
um but yeah man it's it's breathing
rarefied [ __ ] air when you get to
walk around and like there are people
that cosplay as you but i get to kind of
cosplay as me too it's fun i'm my own
[ __ ] character um we've been selling
a bunch of stuff at san diego comic-con
and so we've had uh wonderful
partnerships with spirit jersey made
some tremendous [ __ ] clothes for us
man as well as the good folks at
roosevelt's made some [ __ ] beautiful
clothes first as well um before we dive
into things let me pull up jc uh i'm
sorry let me pull up [ __ ] i was
looking that way let me pull up uh
[ __ ] luke to tell us about what we
have
sold here at the movies uh pop-up so far
it's a little self-serving kids but
[ __ ] you know
that's what i do is self-serve
give it up for luke everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
um
use the force
luke has been selling merch for the last
uh two days of the con what are we
selling what sells the most
right
the entire staff here is dressed in the
roosevelt stuff jake bring that bring
your [ __ ] sexy ass over on camera
and show people what it looks like the
other one hurling hawking merchandise at
you is jake give it up for jake
everybody
what
luke and jake work in office they are
also filmmakers as well they work in the
office part-time in real life they're
filmmakers today they're selling
merchandise this is what the roosevelt
shirt looks like
[Music]
and there's a purple one uh that's
designed like the movie spock as well
but the staff has been wearing them here
all the time and it's so lovely to walk
in and just see like a bunch of [ __ ]
where i'm like i created that i'm
responsible for that i'm my name is on
that what has been selling the most
since we've been here
i didn't know we saw movies funko pops
kids
i think we're the only people that sell
the movies funko pop
i've not seen them in like [ __ ]
spencer gifts or i never see our pops in
the real world man
i would like to think it's that but i
think they're like we only made nine
and you have them all
um what else is going on
we're gonna give those out as prizes
yeah so tonight when we do give him this
one take this
so tonight when we do the q a at uh the
halfway point man uh we're gonna give
out that and we're gonna give out that
and what's the other one we're giving
out we're giving out that so i'm going
to ask a question banff man we'll let
you in and you might win one of these
fine [ __ ] prizes
all right boys thank you give it up for
the boys they've been working already
[Applause]
[Music]
um
now yeah i haven't done anything con
orion today regarded con oriented today
regarding
others like i got up this morning i went
and did press at ew and did ign then i
went on the con floor
at 1 30 and and uh took pictures at the
lions gate uh quick stop booth um but
i've had my ear to the ground for news
yeah and as you said you actually waited
in a line on the ground and i did pour
some [ __ ] marvel animated panel news
so i read it all on twitter
but i'm glad you actually went man like
because one of us was represented there
i we were and i i got to see the things
that twitter couldn't tell you that they
saw is that right well they screened an
episode of i am groot the little series
of shorts how was it it's so [ __ ]
cute is it it was this the one they
showed was uh groot takes a bath
and it's like groot just and it's vin
diesel he's voice and groots like just
kind of powering through some forest and
sees a puddle of uh
of water and he climbs into the puddle
and he goes like suddens himself down
and puts some cucumbers on his eyes and
he gets out of the water and he's
covered in little tiny leaves
and then he starts doing a fashion show
because he can cut the leaves into like
a ball gown and a little soldier's hat
and uh
it's [ __ ] adorable it is so sweet
you'll get cavities it's adorable but
now that they're adding r-rated movies
i'm looking forward to groot takes a
[ __ ] that's the one that i want to
[ __ ] see did you hear they had a
deadpool and and logan i know deadpool
logan and deadpool 2 are now on disney
plus some people have speculated online
that that's uh like they did that this
suspiciously this weekend because maybe
at the marvel panel they announced
something about deadpool 3. i think it
has more to do with the fact that their
deals probably just lapsed at other
places and now they could be there
bringing them home and also like the
other one of the things they announced
was marvel zombies
which is a spin-off from the what if
episode where chad marvel zombies so
wait they're going to do a whole show
marvel series about marvel zombies which
was insanely popular in the comics for
like a red hot minute it was you know
and that's going to be a like r rated
[ __ ] cartoon because zombies because
of all the cool violence yeah violence
and gore
um so they showed an iam groot they
showed a whole ass episode of what if
season two
are you [ __ ] me yeah like they ended
the panel with do you want to watch one
yeah
and so we watched one which so it's
season two what episode it is um what if
um what the [ __ ] i wrote it down didn't
i i think i did such a memorable episode
i did it no but it was it was like what
if
captain carter
meets
armored winter soldier
oh [ __ ] and so the armored winter
soldier is steve rogers
hey guys
i know
but
you wanted to know what it was so i told
you
i
sounded like somebody was jumping like
spoiler
i mean he was coming at me
that was your [ __ ] john wilkes booth
right there man
i hate your takes
can't grab a water um all right so so
yes
but it's dope like those the [ __ ]
what if we're all dope you know the
animation is beautiful the action is
insane
and you know they get select members of
the voice cast to come back but haley
atwell is always going to be captain
carter in animation and in live action
at this point and then they you know
they don't get [ __ ] chris evans back
but they get a dude who sounds like him
and they don't get
you know other characters back but
enough of them are sound alikes that
it's super [ __ ] cool i know this is
unrelated but you said chris evans and
in my head i had to shuffle through all
the chris's and as i did i was like wait
chris pine did you know that [ __ ]
chris pine is in this
dungeons and dragons movie i did they
dropped the trailer yesterday and it's
fun
now like did you hey did everybody know
there was a d d movie coming
[Music]
b did everybody know that chris pine was
in it
where the [ __ ] have i been man i have no
idea it's chris pine and michelle
rodriguez playing a barbarian which is
adorable
um not because she couldn't be a
barbarian but it's
[ __ ] adorable um and then reggae john
page from bridgeton um did you watch any
bridgettes
somebody was like yeah
that [ __ ] dude who took his pants off
a lot i was gonna say if you're asking
if i saw his dick yes i'm familiar with
his work
he was excellent on saturday live very
funny host very charming well the thing
that and it's in the trailers there's
not a spoiler but the thing they save in
the spoil in the trailer that they
reveal at the very end of it is that
chris pine is playing a bard
which is
right
the silliest character you can play in
guns and dragons is that right is the
dude who shows up with his loot to sing
songs well everybody else is doing like
dungeons and dragon fightings and [ __ ]
and he's like well
here we go for a little ditty don't we
so it's
it sounds like he comes with a loot but
then [ __ ] brings the death later on
like i'm sure they raise him to the hero
like no he just plays music the whole
time
uh i don't it looks fun look and it's
hard to differentiate from like nine
different dragon things that we're
seeing like all right so there's the
house of the dragon on that and then
there's more dragons over there there's
probably a dragon or two in the rings of
power show i don't know [ __ ] there's
elves at least probably dragons speaking
of the rings of power show men a huge
congratulations to our friend bear
mccreary who did the score for masters
universe revelations
he just got the [ __ ] job scoring
amazon lord of the rings show what does
it call i can't say it it sounds like a
lord of the rings rings of power rings
of power it just sounds like a [ __ ]
power bottom we're just waiting for you
to put [ __ ] rings of power yes
um
hey man welcome everybody banff man's
here
uh wasn't
bear mccreary supposed to do splinter he
was just bumped for lord of the rings i
absolutely did
um he was supposed to say he was
supposed to write the score for my short
film um and then probably about two
months ago he was like man i can't i
just can't fit it it's i can't even tell
you why but i just i gotta pull out and
i was like don't man just leave it in
it's like i wanted to [ __ ] me like a
bear
mccreary but yes clearly this was the
thing and even though he it was just
announced he's been working on it for a
good long while yeah um huge job i
remember at one point i was like oh my
god
that's huge for bear and then i stopped
and thought about it because i've worked
with bear and i've seen his work and his
work elevated our our cartoon
um i was like that's [ __ ] huge for
the rings man like he's a great get for
them he is perfect for that job that guy
yeah um
so yeah so marvel animation they they
green lit second seasons for a bunch of
shows i'm groot is getting a second
season
spider-man freshman year they showed a
bunch of designs for that what is that
show exactly that is that is his
freshman year in high school
um by the looks of it because it is a
simpler college it's a prequel like it
feels like it's high school
i think it's meant to be and this i
could be wrong i wasn't there you were
at the panel but based on what i read
online it's meant to
fill in the gaps between the next
spider-man movie it's it's freshman year
in college i don't think so is that
right maybe i could have read it [ __ ]
wrong because they're talking very much
about like
here's the mentor that he gets before
tony stark
which in this show is is norman osborne
i know right so they're doing like a
marvel cinematic universe pre-story yeah
because they never have it they haven't
really done norman osborn yet yeah
interesting so and you know seeing guys
with [ __ ] letterman jackets running
around the halls what looks like a high
school
like this feels high schooly so would
the so would his outfit be like the
outfit peter was wearing when tony first
came to meet him the pajama outfit yeah
that's the design
it's similar to it not exactly to it but
there's the here's the very beginnings
of [ __ ] spider-man before he gets the
tony stark jam all right i'm down for
that show too i thought this was the
show that was meant to go
between
spider-man movies to be like this is
what happens when he went to college so
that we could just jump into the next
adventure but that sounds good too yeah
they backed it up so they're doing a
spider-man sophomore year they've
already announced season two
has the the first one hasn't even come
out now
we like it a lot and the big news out of
that was that one of the characters in
the cartoon is going to be daredevil
which will be voiced by charlie cox oh
[ __ ] really
yeah
god they're going hardcore on cox aren't
they man i know we all do but [ __ ]
like thank the lord they're really like
he's our daredevil across every version
of our universe they're taking that cox
deep
take it all to cox um good for them man
what else what other news do they have
do we have a cartoon there yet we don't
know oh sorry
uh yeah they showed some uh some
animatics from x-men 97
which uh which looks exactly like x-men
97 always looked uh but better
you know like a little more fluid
but the the character models are
essentially the same like storms in
order for it to work in order for it to
work they got a lot of the same voice
cast back um that's amazing which is you
know watching them in the booth like the
woman who played rogue is playing rogue
again the dude who played logan is
playing logan again it's kind of great
that is awesome and the music is the
music and it's exactly what you want it
to be
[Music]
exactly that so that was the highlight
of that was getting to see an episode
getting to see some of groot um and just
getting to see some of the design work
for zombies and for spider-man stuff and
x-men and yeah look dope [ __ ] a man
right on all right so there's news of a
panel that you actually went to give it
up for mark he went to a thing i did a
thing
it's like the old days man when you were
[ __ ] a newshound you had to go do a
thing i know i mean the whole h i want
to see some [ __ ]
and camp out all day long all right
uh what other news is there um comic-con
there was some some walking dead news
oh
that uh that after a very long time away
from the walking dead andrew lincoln and
danai guerrero are going to be back as
rick grimes and michonne
for a spin-off series of their own
following their the events of their
characters after we last saw rick end up
on a helicopter at the end of season
nine i think that was
so they're coming back and they're just
continuing that story and this love
story that uh in a dead world can love
survive
robert kirkman just the richest person
we know man good for him that show just
won't end i mean even though even though
the mothership is ending apparently this
fall they've got the carol and daryl
power hour
they've got now a request did she drop
didn't she drop out
isn't it just the daryl power half hour
the daryl and daryl and my other brother
daryl yes
um i think there were some issues with
her and i'm not be she might be a guest
star and not the the main thrust of the
show but
they're still doing that they're doing
the tales of the walking dead anthology
um the dead shall never die apparently
hey man good for them amc still of
course amc i was in the elevator at the
hotel and i think i saw
uh an interview with a vampire is an amc
show ian reister when's that begin
uh soon i think actually that's
[ __ ] huge for them man like it's a
built-in audience for those books yeah
and who doesn't love vampires yeah
absolutely everybody does apparently um
and then the other bit of news that i
saw on the internets before i came over
is it's very comic book related is that
todd mcfarland as a writer and greg
capullo as an artist are collaborating
on batman spawn
number one oh [ __ ]
actual comic book news actual comic book
news there'll be a 48 page one shot
that's coming out december 13th
um is it a sequel to the previous batman
spawn or
it was unclear if it's continuing that
song i bought that when it came out but
that was like what 2005 long [ __ ]
time ago yeah so so yeah it's
the two biggest dudes doing some of the
best work of their careers and greg
capullo is now a definitive batman
artist and it's [ __ ] todd mcfarlane
[ __ ] hey man um i'll buy that for
sure i like that i love batman just and
i loved when they did the one years ago
like batman could
didn't have to hold back like i remember
he threw like [ __ ]
bat shuriken into his [ __ ] face into
spawn's face
so they might go
way more violent with the character than
they normally do it'd be fun to see and
it sounds like todd will probably do a
cover at least at least yeah that's
awesome man uh no more comic book news
that's all i got man anybody got any
other comic-con news that we don't see
[ __ ] that was cool
that's not news
but thank you very much i saw on my
twitter feed all day long
that um i guess jim lee was doing a
panel and somebody asked him about the
snyder verse and he said something like
uh there right now there's no plans for
any more zack snyder's nervous and as
you would imagine
twitter lit the [ __ ] up
that's not news because warner brothers
said it like i thought six months ago
that's what i thought i think some
people felt like oh man like you know
that ain't i saw some people being like
that can't be true what does he know and
i'm like i think he would no
he seems rather high up there
he would know some [ __ ] but yeah i still
don't understand why they can't i know
jim lee ain't in charge of this so this
has nothing to do with him but
in the vast [ __ ] warner brothers
empire you got hbo max give him a thing
every year let him do a thing every
[ __ ] year man everyone's happy at the
very [ __ ] least that he gets to
continue on the snyder verse but it
seems so
strange that they're just like nah we're
done we're done we're done moving on
well i mean they dc films still have
some work to do to figure out who
they're going to be right like they got
to decide what their their version of dc
universe actually is
how does
you know flash and shazam and black adam
and and batgirl
all make sense together as something and
something new because and to be fair
they spent a decade in zack snyder's
version of that and they told their
story apparently zach i'm sure would
tell more stories but i guess warner
brothers feels like all right we
we gave it a go and we made some money
but we did make as much as we wanted and
the the fans and the critics didn't love
it as much as you wanted to generally
some loved it to death because there's
always people who love a thing but now i
think they they want to try something
new they just don't know what that is
yet
um did the dc panel happen the mar
warner brothers movie panel that's
tomorrow morning that's when they're
doing black adam that's when they're
doing black adam with apparently
surprise guest henry cavill
in the house rumored to be there i read
that online as well henry cavill's
supposed to be there and that's why
the whole like oh there are no plans is
weird because it's like but wait
superman's coming do you think that
means if henry cavill does indeed come
that he's perhaps
in black adam
i mean it always felt odd to me that
because naturally the the the
the way it would work the getting the
yang of it is
black adam and shazam yes like those are
the two that's the the bonded pair
absolutely but the shazam that they've
built
is a bit comical intentionally and very
kid-friendly and very kid-friendly like
it's so zach levi does a great job with
the character for sure but those feel
like two completely different movies
right that are trying to do two
different tones and so maybe a way to
bridge that gap
is to bring henry cavill in and then
maybe you get a kingdom come
oh [ __ ] and so if you do
like older superman and you gray [ __ ]
henry cavill temples and then you get
that whole story then you can do a
slightly older gal gadot you can you can
actually bring it all together and end
that story
in kingdom come and let zack snyder
direct it
it's [ __ ] a good idea man you should
be running that universe over there
[ __ ]
well
i am currently unemployed
it sounds at the very least though that
link maybe that's what they're headed
toward like
if i if i was a betting person
you know
dwayne the rock johnson's gonna be here
there's no way he loves his movie and
has been supporting this for
over 10 years a decade before it even
existed and stuff
um i wouldn't be surprised if they
announced like [ __ ] even before the
movies come out that they're like
working on black adam too and it's black
adam versus
superman that's what they'll use
superman from now he just verses
everybody
so he versed about he feed batman next
to the [ __ ] black adam and [ __ ] i
mean it's a bit like the way marvel uses
the hulk and that they are not going to
do a hulk movie again for various
reasons chiefly because the rights are
tied up with universal they have a claim
in it right but he can be a supporting
character in every movie
and so like hey maybe we need another
superman movie because for reasons that
escape me they can't crack superman yeah
i know
whatever
they seem to be doing just fine over on
cw
yeah and have been doing for a while
yeah lots of people figured out superman
except for the movies yeah
but hey
who am i to say i'm just a i'm just a
consumer you just had the job and now
you just lost it oh well
i never really had it um
any other news that we didn't hit
going once going twice anybody seen a
cool cosplay on the floor
get over here man [ __ ] look at this
come join us kids
blunt man and chronic are in the hizzy
kids
can you see them there
yeah there you go parade look at that
look at that
here take the microphone
why on earth would you cosplay as
characters nobody [ __ ] knows cause
they're [ __ ] sick
dude
okay but i've been watching your [ __ ]
movies ever since i was like 15 years
old oh man and so
i
it was like 10 30 at night and i
messaged her saying black men and
chronic question mark yeah
and it's one of those cosplays is like
if you [ __ ] know
you know
and so sometimes those are the best
rather than just like
superman and [ __ ] like that
[ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that
i thank my brother every day for making
me so [ __ ] cool because he like
raised me to be so into all the [ __ ] jay
and silent bob all the other [ __ ]
movies we watched so thank you gerardo i
love you
oh
it's looking adorable
now uh how long have you been just doing
this today
yeah just today how many now how do
people go who are you no um not here
obviously here people get it but like in
the real world
like does a doctor strange look down on
you two and [ __ ]
a cosplaying doctor strange he's like
staying real well to be fair we're
actually cosplayers so that's true
you're just dressed up but have you had
people be like i don't get it nah
[ __ ] it they're just looking at her up
and down like
it's cause my nipples are out
[Music]
yeah that's something j muse couldn't
pull off man
tried i was like take him out he's like
nope
put him on the glass
i literally had a guy she was walking
here and i was behind her and she would
just turn around around and he was just
like
and i was just like oh he doesn't know
he doesn't know
what a horrifying story that was
give it up for the ladies man blunt man
and chronic
excellent job kids thank you oh i love
you i love you as well i love you too
another cosplayer come on up man we
didn't know this is the cosplay show
it's silent bob hill or your camera turn
around
[Applause]
look at the blow up boom box how
adorable man
take the mic no don't give me the mike
he's silent oh that's right you're
silent
you're doing a [ __ ] excellent job
right there killing it now take the mic
i i let you pull out of character for
this because i must know
can you get laid off of this look
i've been married for 16 years and
thanks to you my wife hates goodbye
horses now oh [ __ ] you're a tucker i
knew it i play it every night [ __ ] it it
still makes it happen though does it
really oh yeah it still works tucker the
man in his dream
has anybody been like who are you
uh no i get a lot of uh a lot of like
hey the bob hey the bob is here and i'm
like yeah but see i wish like i wish
we'd been standing next to each other
just to see
hopefully i'd beat you
and they're like oh he looks better than
you true man it's true if i wear a mask
you might win and [ __ ] if i take the
mask off though at that point they're
like he looks like the real thing
just older
no i just i want to personally thank you
for all your films uh i mean you're such
an inspiration to a lot of people and me
especially
thank you so
damn much man
absolutely thank you all right who
dressed up like mark bernardin
you [ __ ] up pricks there's a
nah man there's a black dude over there
in a spider-man t-shirt he's just
walking away
come on homie you've got to represent
yeah come on up i like that i like the
la mark bernard cosplay
see look that's me
mark bernard and cosplay right there
absolute pleasure
take that mic
i'm just here supporting my boy right
there who's like the biggest kevin smith
fan ever so when i see him coming up
here bantering with you i'm like i have
to get you you're the you're the dutiful
friend i meet you so often when somebody
comes out that was him uh he was a uh he
was telling bob
when i meet people who are so ecstatic
to me me there's usually somebody
standing next to him who's patient as a
[ __ ] saint
and i'm always like i know who you are
you're like my wife in these situations
the dutiful friend who's like is this
[ __ ] done yet
so it's very kind of you to to be his
companion it is a blessing just being
here
in your guy's presence you guys are
amazing thank you guys thank you damn
pleasure
how sweet
um all right banff man uh shall we dive
to some q a yeah we're gonna do some q a
all right man that means banff man's
gonna pick some people to ask some
questions we'll bring you up here you
take this mic you ask us questions we
like that question you get to pick one
of these fine [ __ ] prizes a children
mall rat ladies and gentlemen silent bob
or jay or assigned movies funko pop man
oh really and we got this [ __ ] too never
mind that the pot got sweeter man
there's two only two sets
two of these prizes will come with 40x
tickets
so you can go see whatever's playing in
40x and if you've never seen a 40x movie
the chair [ __ ] you to death it's
amazing it's like a thrill ride and a
movie at the same time all right what's
your name captain name's andrew and
andrew and we'll give it up for andrew
he's first
[Applause]
all right uh so this question is mostly
for you kevin um i know that you wrote
clerks three like a while ago and it's
been
we you've been reworking it over and
over again yeah i know at one point you
guys did a script reading of like the
original version of it yep uh would you
ever consider doing like a what if
type of thing like a like a comic or a
maybe release the script i'll do you one
better do you have his sound at all or
should i repeat for him
yeah can you hear him
done and done um then i'll go straight
to the ends i didn't know if i had to
repeat it i couldn't hear you coming out
of the mic um
when we did a live reading of that
version of clerks three which we did as
a benefit for the first avenue playhouse
when you see people auditioning for the
movie in clerks 3 we shot that at
shot it
and it was it was really [ __ ]
powerful man and so we'll put it up
after the real ones on video so everyone
can [ __ ] see the difference and stuff
and then probably i've got a comic book
label imprint that's starting in
september called secret stash press with
dark horse comics i think we'll we might
do
the old script as a comic book to just
show you the alternate version of what
clerks three would have been in a comic
book form and you get away with doing
cool [ __ ] like that
so yes um
do you have anything for mark though uh
i haven't read adore yet i'm so sorry i
would ask you about that i just want to
say that i do love you oh equally yes
thank you as much as kevin i've been
watching you guys for years you guys
have both shaped my like geekiness so
it's been it's an honor to be talking to
you guys
andrew wins this man well done andrew
give it up for andrew
well done my friend i'll take that
microphone back
hey okay you can give should we do this
one for questions probably
thank you all right next what's your
name my name is linda it's great great
to meet you thank you give it up for
linda man hi
[Music]
so there's a slide over which would be
better this side
right there done and done
so there's a lot of collaborators
potentially here at san diego comic con
what's the collaboration
that you'd like to do with anyone at
comic-con that you haven't done yet what
a great question you're definitely going
to win them all right
you
start
um
it's funny i had breakfast with a friend
this morning and he was like well what's
the next thing you want to work on
and i started telling him the story of
this this movie that i want to write
like it could be a tv show but it's
probably a movie and he was like
that's dope i love it
what's the next step and it's like well
i think if i'm going to pitch this thing
and get somebody who paid me to write it
i'm probably need to attach a director
to this movie
in order to sort of get over the hump of
is this a real thing is this actually
you know viable property like we like
the idea but blah blah blah blah
and he was like well who's the who's the
director you want i was like there's
really only one person he said you would
be perfect for this who gets you in the
door
brings all the relevant experience and
expertise to the thing that you want he
said who is it i'm happy to do it
ask the answer
who was it really
it was you i was [ __ ] serious yeah i
thought i was joking i was joking around
not at all i was like it's it's it's
kevin smith or bust i think what is it
i'm gonna tell you now oh oh oh you
weren't telling me to like keep your
[ __ ] it's true and i'm not gonna
spill it
i forgot all these people seriously
oh we'll talk we got to wrap the show up
kids because
i talk about our future oh really really
it's [ __ ] dope man all right yeah so
we'll have a chat but it's it's legit
the thing that that i'm like he's really
the only other person i can imagine to
to do this thing
a new baby has been born i knew and you
watched it you watched it go deep
deep in long and hard
i mean
i was gonna say blunt man and chronic in
a marvel movie but [ __ ] that's way
better
you get to pick which one which one you
like
give it up first she won and you got the
tickets too
yeah they're both yours
she took the j what an insult
what's your name captain uh my name is
rob what is it rob everyone running for
rob man thank you everyone
uh let me start off by saying thank you
thank you for the entertainment thank
you for all the enjoyment you've given
us over the years thank you i grew up on
your stuff and it's just incredibly
awesome thank you for that man um so i'd
like to ask you both yes you guys have
had an amazing career you've had some
amazing opportunities been a good run
thanks for coming
let me ask you this what have you passed
up that you regret
oh
what a great [ __ ] quest take that
[ __ ] mall right now man there we go
[Applause]
oh my god i really don't have a
life of regrets or a career of regret uh
either but there's definitely some [ __ ]
we could talk about here what do you
what are you
you know it's uh
it's funny because similarly i don't
want to live a life of regret and i
think that every choice
that i've been lucky enough to make has
brought me to the place that i needed to
be
that said there had been some mistakes
along the way of some of those choices
um that you can learn from that you can
process and you can you can you know
turn into ammunition for what comes next
but there was a point in which i had two
shows two opportunities to choose from
two two different two different tv shows
i can't say the one that i chose but i
can say that the one that i didn't
choose was the third season of the
witcher
why didn't you ask me
i would have been like [ __ ] do it
what happened tell the story all i can i
mean i had a lovely meeting with the
showrunners and the producers and i knew
a couple people who'd be on it would
have been great and i and i legitimately
i'm a richer fan i was never a deep fan
of the of the books but like i loved the
show i played the game it was amazing
the show's great and so to get to play
in that world would have been phenomenal
except for what the other thing was
ah
there was something [ __ ] better and i
can't say what it was
that's not what it is will we be seeing
it soon uh i don't know how soon soon is
but definitely in the next couple of
years knowing what i know you made the
right choice
but it was just like spoilers i
i i i had to do the thing because i
would have regret i would have regretted
not doing it that said like [ __ ] the
witchers the witcher like it would have
been amazing so and those are the you
know the kinds of
the choices that i'm lucky to have to
make
is between two things that i love and
two things that are great and two things
that could help advance my career and
there's no winner or loser in that
choice there's just gut feeling it's
just i think i got to do this all right
is the money the same no [ __ ] i think i
still got to do this
and so yeah hopefully i'll be able to
say before the end of the year what the
other thing was and then maybe you'll
understand why i chose it um but yeah it
was that
give it up for mark that's an excellent
[ __ ] tale
how about you kevin
well i'm gonna start with and i don't
this is not a regret but this was an
opportunity that was afforded to me and
i feel like i was wise enough to know
that i was not
the right choice
um
me and scott mosher uh my podcast buddy
uh and the guy who produced like all the
early movies
um we were friends with this upcoming
actor uh name of ben affleck and him and
his buddy matt damon had written a
script that they sold to castle rock
for almost a million dollars like it was
a spec script that they sold for 800
grand
castle rock wasn't moving forward on
that movie so i met ben makin maul rats
we became friends he's [ __ ] one of
the most likable funniest people
in the world jennifer lopez is a lucky
lucky woman
um
he
he
as our you know friendship
grew
like i he would talk more about goodwill
hunting first day i met him when he came
into auditions
i had read the day before or that
morning as a matter of fact that him and
matt his friend had sold the script it
was in the hollywood reporter so when he
came in to audition for mall rats i was
like the [ __ ] are you doing here man
like you just sold the script for 800
000
and he was shocked he was like how the
[ __ ] do you know that i was like i read
the trades he was like you're too young
to read the trades and he was younger
than me
so you know um i had always been
checking in like how's good will hunting
doing and [ __ ] and he would leave maul
rats
to set him all rats like because he
didn't shoot every day he would uh he
came to me one time he was like hey man
uh like rob reiner wants to meet
about uh goodwill hunting because rob
reiner was one of the co-heads of castle
rock and uh i was like yeah go meet
meathead that sounds amazing he played
[ __ ] meathead on all in the family
some people like you just called rob
reiner me that the whole world did at
one [ __ ] point and [ __ ]
so he would go back and have meetings
and there was somebody at castle rock uh
one of the partners not rob reiner that
wanted to direct the movie um and the
boys were like no we think it should be
gus fonson who had directed
ben's brother in a movie uh called to
die for and so they all knew him and
everyone loved gus he's an amazing
director so they had always seen gus as
the guy to direct good wanting and
because of the deal that they made as a
spec script
they had the ability to say no to
everybody and so they were saying no to
everyone that they threw their way and
including
this
partner who wanted to direct the movie
and to be fair this partner had directed
films before but the boys were like no
man like this movie belongs to gus in
our head and hearts
so at a certain point castle rock got
frustrated and they were like look take
this movie out we're gonna let give you
a window if you could sell it to
somebody else and we get our money back
fine we'll walk away clean but if you
can't in two months it comes back to us
and this deal about director approval
goes away
and we're gonna [ __ ] bring in the
director we want and also we're gonna
bring in the cast that we want because
ben and matt were attached to star but
castle rock had their eye on two other
very hot upcoming actors uh name of uh
leonardo dicaprio and spiderman whatever
the [ __ ] toby mcguire
that's who they wanted for that movie
and that's a completely different
director as well so
uh ben in a hail mary [ __ ] goes hey
man like you work at miramax can you get
this script in there maybe they'll buy
it because it feels like a max movie and
i was like i don't know man like [ __ ]
like it's going to be weird for me to
walk in and be like a friend of mine
wrote a script he plays a bully in the
movie i just finished and [ __ ]
and i was like send me the script i'll
read it and i'll let you know so they
fedex me to script and because you
couldn't just [ __ ] text it to
somebody in those days you actually had
to [ __ ] mail it he fedex me the
script i got it i took it into the
bathroom at this condo i was living in
red bank sat down i figured i'd read the
first few pages while i was taking a
[ __ ] i did not get up for two hours i
[ __ ] in the first three minutes and i
just kept turning the [ __ ] page you
know it's a very emotional movie it's
about the end of the script i'm bawling
my eyes out i come out of the bathroom
when i'm done scott mosher was like what
happened in there
and i was like got a transformative
experience i can't believe it [ __ ]
ben affleck and his friend wrote like
the best [ __ ] script i've ever read
he goes [ __ ] i was like [ __ ] read
this and so scott read it and he was
like this is [ __ ] dope so we brought
it into miramax miramax bought the flick
they had to pay more than castle rocket
paid for it castle rock paid 800 grand
for it miramax had to go over the top
because of expenses and [ __ ] they paid a
million bucks for it so on the day that
the deal closed
this i don't i will never know if this
was because they were serious or if this
was because they felt like well he
helped bring this [ __ ] in so we should
[ __ ] ask
but uh the head of miramax whose name
we'll leave out because we're all having
a good [ __ ] time
as well as ben and matt themselves were
like do you want to direct
because i was the director friend
and i brought the project in and it was
a project about dudes that talk to each
other
and you know i had done that a few times
so in that moment i was like you know
what man no i was like i'll be honest i
love this script it made me cry on the
[ __ ] i said and i'll take some
credits what i should have said was put
me in the [ __ ]
but i've well we got me and scott got
like ass prod credit co-executive
producer credits or something but i said
like look you uh you don't need me you
like if i wish to direct this i would
constantly turn around to the writers
and be like what did you see when you
wrote this because that's the only way i
knew how to translate my [ __ ] so i was
like i will ruin this by turning to the
writers constantly at that point just
hire the writers to direct it and that
was never going to be the case i
remember the exact quote was like ben
affleck can never direct a movie
it was years before so
i backed the boy's original play which
was gus like it should go to gus and for
the next six months miramax didn't
commit to gus they had everybody come in
in a miramax vault somewhere i mean
whoever owns that [ __ ] i think it's
paramount now is 20 minutes of
what do they used to call that [ __ ] in
the movie business where the screen test
where michael mann the director of heat
directed 20 minutes of goodwill hunting
with scenes of ben and matt and their
friends just to see if he liked how they
were as actors and [ __ ] at one point mel
gibson was real close to directing uh at
one point who else was on the list
[ __ ] daniel stern it was crazy so
many people wanted to direct that movie
but when they asked me do you want to
direct it i was like i would ruin this
and thank god i didn't because
gus did an amazing job and they won
awards and [ __ ] so that one i don't
regret
right like maybe a year later because
you got to remember now i'm like kevin
smith i'm like oh he made clerks 96 and
[ __ ] like that
but there was a moment in the 90s where
i was like a hot commodity so at one
point i'm working on a screenplay for
superman at warner brothers and the head
of warner brothers is lorenzo de
bonaventura he went on to produce the
transformers movies he left warner
brothers became a producer and [ __ ] back
then he was running warner brothers
ahead of production
so you know i've been working on
superman i told that [ __ ] story a
zillion times uh lorenzo was like why
don't you come over my house uh to have
dinner and i was like oh my god
absolutely he's the [ __ ] head of the
studio and i like the guy so i go to his
house uh like uh i i always try to
remember where it was because i drive
the hollywood hills all the time i just
remember it was like up a real windy
[ __ ] place and [ __ ] we got there he
had a cook who [ __ ] cooked for us and
[ __ ] and we sat there both eating
[ __ ] and talked about chasing amy
because that was coming next i was like
uh we'd already been to sundance and
[ __ ] i think at that point
and so lorenzo dibanovichura who's in
charge
at warner brothers
this is 1996-7
so i want to say late 96 early 97.
he goes you know
i've been thinking about this this is a
true [ __ ] story swearing my mother's
[ __ ] grave we get [ __ ] lorenzo and
he'll back it up because i've been
thinking about this there are a lot more
characters
in this dc like toy box than just batman
and superman we're always making batman
and superman and you seem to know a lot
about this [ __ ]
so
what would you think about running a
division of warner brothers
where all you do is develop superhero
movies for us to make
wow
and in that meal right there at the
dinner
i was like no man i'm about to make
dogma like i i
like i said like
i said uh i was like that sounds like a
dream job but it also sounds like a job
for somebody who wants to be an
executive and stuff i said are you
trying to get me out of the movie
business to just develop because i suck
as a director he goes no dodo and i said
well yeah i got to do my thing i was
like i've been trying to make this dogma
movie since i wrote it before clerks so
i i don't think i'm your guy
and
you know i'm happy i went and made dogma
um
[Applause]
but modern day kevin smith
would be like oh i know how to do both
because i'll be stoned for all of it you
know it wouldn't have been threatening
or intimidating it would have been
something that i was like oh [ __ ] yeah
i'll take that on even if i did it for a
couple years and then [ __ ] off and did
my own [ __ ] or this is how little i
thought of myself i was offered a whole
division i could have just been like oh
i'm developing this and i'm going to
direct it myself but i never thought of
myself as a comic book movie director so
that didn't factor into the math so
years later man like after seeing what
kevin feige did with the marvel
cinematic universe which to be fair i
never would have had the breath of
vision to do myself i don't think i
would have i'm not that inventive case
in point next up clerks three
so
so i don't feel like the world missed
out or something like that by stretching
the imagination but i do
recognize now that like i could have
said yes
and
life would have taken a weirdly
different turn again doesn't mean those
movies would have been good
you know maybe it would have ended my
[ __ ] career period as it stands now
i've got a career where i can build my
own path if nobody wants to work with me
i'm like ah [ __ ] off i'll be over here
until you're ready again then i'd do
some [ __ ] and then they're like oh come
back and then i go play with them again
and stuff so i have no regrets i love
the career of kevin smith and i don't
mean that in a royal way just i as a fan
of kevin smith the world's biggest kevin
smith fan i like the career choices of
kevin smith that being said
i probably just should have said [ __ ]
yes in that room
like i could have been [ __ ] kevin smith
i could have been kevin feige for
[ __ ] warner brothers and [ __ ] the
best kevin in the world to be man
so
i do every once in a while i go [ __ ] man
maybe i should have just said yes
instead of
you know i was a kid man and all i
wanted to do was make my [ __ ] i could
not [ __ ] believe that i was able to
make the things that i was able to make
that they were letting me make mall rats
or [ __ ] chase name or now we were on
the breath of the doorstep of [ __ ]
dogma so i couldn't
see past that i was happy to write for
him and i told him i was like all right
all the superhero movies you want i said
but like nah when it comes to directing
i just do my [ __ ] and you know years
later i would go play in the cw sandbox
and it would be comfortable because
those were only like nine day jobs and
[ __ ] still to this day i don't regret
never making a superhero movie i think
that's for meant for very visually
talented people i like and and that's
also my go-to
jam like that's my safe place that's my
happy place i don't want to go work in
that happy place ruin it and then it's
no longer a happy place for me like oh i
can't watch comic book movies because i
made one and it flopped and [ __ ] now i
can watch them and just love them to
death and [ __ ] and rarely judge them
like never am i like oh this is a bad
comic movie i'm just like well that's
better than i could [ __ ] ever do
and take my hat off not literally
because i never [ __ ] take my hat off
but i take my hat off figuratively to
them um what a great question i'll tell
you what a long answer kevin thank you
for dogma i'm glad you did it
damn pleasure take your tickets take
your silent bob your goddamn winner
what a weird wonderful walk down memory
lane kids have you had a good time this
evening man
we got to talk to ryan what's up dr ryan
oh my god we're not even [ __ ] done
ladies and gentlemen i forgot we got a
guest man uh joining us right now from
golden apple comics man
the world's greatest comic book store
even [ __ ] considering i own one uh
golden apple been doing it for [ __ ]
ever
uh i remember seeing
a
entertainment
tonight piece 1989 when batman was
coming out
and they went to golden apple to shoot a
piece about the merchandising like all
the toys that they were selling all you
know and they showed a bunch of comic
book covers and the guy who ran the
store bill leibowitz was like being
interviewed on tv and [ __ ]
and i had that saved on a vhs for years
because i'd watch it over and over again
because i was a huge
fan of batman and a huge fan of the
movie that was coming and stuff and we
didn't have access to like the internet
and trailers at that point so anything
you could save you saved so i watched
that [ __ ] tape to death and then
years later i was 89 1994 i come out to
los angeles because of clerks for the
first time and one of the first things i
did was like does golden apple still
exist and [ __ ] and they're like yeah
it's over on melrose and i went to
melrose walked in and [ __ ] there the
bill leibowitz was working who to me was
one of the most famous [ __ ] people in
the world because i saw him on the
center to name it entertainment tonight
piece and i was like oh my god dude you
were on tv he was like six years ago i
was like yeah but i have it saved on a
vhs i must have come off as so [ __ ]
creepy you know
in any event man uh the leverwitz is
still own uh golden apple and ryan is
the guy that runs it now ryan's here to
talk about this golden apple initiative
that uh is about to uh about help saving
comics join us right now ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the show ryan
you wanna join us are there which is
easier either way come sit with us man
pull up a chair
uh
[Music]
ryan just came from a a panel did you
have a panel right before this
i had a panel yesterday yesterday
you were talking to some other bill yes
i was talking instead of on our panel mr
wilshere we played that awesome video
that you sent me which was
touching and awesome and you it was a
little snippet you guys got a little
snippet of the video
he sent me that we played in our
presentation yesterday
um
back up one second we started a charity
organization and kevin here graciously
is an advisory board member on it and i
just it means
it means the [ __ ] world to me be
happy to do it man i get to use his name
and like throw that [ __ ] around be like
yeah kevin's on my board so you got to
listen to me now and you found out how
exactly invaluable that is
i can't make it i've got this other guy
i'm talking to but um
no he played this video and just said
all these great things sort of what he
just said but even more
and just a mensch as we would say very
very mr smith my friend friend my family
pleasure to see you too hi
not just on elevators waving to you from
comic-con
um thanks guys for having me here this
is amazing no worries we started some
you know to give back you know we really
want to do something we've been selling
comic books for over 40 years my dad
started golden apple in 1979.
i'm going to move up there you go there
you go otherwise the director told me
what to do i know do you see this
sum total of my direction was like move
up
and uh what does the charity do what's
it called number one so it's called the
golden apple comic and art foundation
it's a real clever name i thought of i
liked it
we had a couple other things and we just
went with that
and um basically one day one of my
oldest customers who's been collecting
comics for like 40 50 years and has
masked one of those giant collections
you guys don't know anything about
like a room or a house full of comics
and toys and [ __ ] right you don't have
any of that at home i'm assuming
so this guy's older so you can only
imagine and he comes in every week he's
a weekly wednesday warrior you know and
um and he's you know he's kind of
wealthy and he's got his he's got his
money
he's a whale thank you and uh
so he's you know here's the thing he
told me that when he dies he was going
to
give all his [ __ ] to the his alma mater
the university of pennsylvania
which is admirable and amazing and i was
like
damn you sure just sell it to me i'll
flip that [ __ ] and make some money you
know like seriously yes i'm a retailer
that's right right i had no idea you
know i'd be here talking about this at
this point he said no like my kids are
good you know we got money we got houses
we got things
he's like they're not touching my comic
books like
if i find out
anyone touch my comic books after i'm
gone like they're dead meat like
they need to go sit
you know and be
celebrated and appreciated for many
years to come
literally the rest of you know all
humanity he wants people to to enjoy him
he's got
crazy runs of x-men and all that good
stuff that you would think he has wow
and he wants people to enjoy it
and he doesn't want to see it sold to
the highest bidder or thrown away or
mismanaged or anything like that
and so he called my wife kendra and i
and was like yeah kendra thank you
justin
that's my guy over there justin
and he called he's like i got a crazy
idea
he's like what if i donate
it all to you and you start a charity
foundation and then you
take it and get it to the university the
proper way and what i learned in this
little you know thing we've been doing
for like six to eight months is that had
he just said hey here's all my [ __ ] they
wouldn't have known what to do with it
but it would be almost a burden for them
it would actually end up in their
basement they admitted this to me and
they'd be like well we got this awesome
collection of comics but we have we
don't know what to do with it we don't
know how much it's worth we don't know a
good one from a bad one makes sense and
so what we're going to do
is we're going to organize it you know
catalog it alphanumeric it bag and board
it do the whole thing
and make sure it's preserved and
protected and organized
a for tax purposes b so we can deliver
this thing like with a bow on top
and so it's it can be actually housed
right across from ben franklin's exhibit
because he started that school it's the
oldest school in the country
and uh they're just like over the moon
wow you're gonna do all this for us i
said yeah this is what we're gonna do so
that's sort of how it started right um
but we sort of taken that with the board
members we've had a few board meetings
by the way
we put your name in the hat but that's
why you're an advisory board member it's
like when you need to know we tell you
exactly
and we made a few decisions and we made
some some leaps and bounds and basically
we want to get into eventually
doing some scholarships
not only for comic book creators people
want to write and draw comics we want to
publish comics maybe colorists letterers
that kind of thing but also near and
dear to my heart and obviously my
father's yeah was retailing you know a
lot of a lot of comic book stores are
started by fans let's let's be very true
let's be honest with your dad they might
not have the background to run a
business and a retail business
especially in this coveted times and all
it is difficult uh it was difficult even
when it's handed to me when my dad
passed 17 years ago and it's difficult
today even more so and but you got to
know budgets and inventory and payroll
passion gets you so far sooner or later
math is involved
so i want to send people to business
school for example get a degree before
they open a comic book store nice things
like that nice man that's [ __ ] smart
we want to preserve comic books and you
know i made a point in the presentation
which maybe i'll throw online maybe i'll
throw your video online at some point
you know
you know one of one is a big deal in the
collectors industry right now you guys
heard that like lebron james triple logo
man so for like two and a half million
dollars it's a one of one i can't
believe it right
every comic book page ever drawn is a
one of one think about that [ __ ]
right they're all original they're there
there's no duplication of those you know
someone painstakingly drew that and then
someone
inked it colored it lettered it the
whole nine right it's a lot of process
you're publishing comics again which by
the way thank god there should be some
good [ __ ] for us to sell come home so
hope brings some people into stores and
stuff my store your store anybody's
store but yeah it's always fun yeah the
the more the mayor so congratulations
for getting back in it because you
didn't have enough to do i'll come do a
signing with you guys because you guys
are right
you heard it you heard it here first
tell these folks um you talked a little
bit about what's it like to be a
multi-generational
retail family like you guys have been at
com you comics your dad made comics his
life your mom's life
and handed it down to you and he made it
your life and you know you could have
been like i don't want this man but you
also
embraced it what is it like being
in comics like the backbone the spine of
the comic industry we talk about the
movies that they make which are amazing
but they don't get to make those movies
unless you sell some [ __ ] comic books
and the person that sells the comic
books is not marvel it's not dc it's the
retailer it's the person like on the
ground level what's it like being part
of that legacy
that's a perfect segue kevin you it's
almost like we planned this
um
so interesting that you would bring this
up this this new charity organization
tonight is sponsoring the eisner awards
if you guys ever heard of that it's like
the oscars
[Music]
our boy right here
[Music]
hopefully mark goes on and wins his team
i hope all our friends win and you know
it's it's great it's like the oscars for
for you know what we do for cool [ __ ]
and
you know my dad won the award on the
like the second year they ever did the
eisner it's called the eisners after
will eisner who's like the grandfather
of you know the graphic novel and just
it's an amazing storyteller
and what did your dad win for retail
yeah so they do a spirit of eisner award
for the best retailer of the of the year
yeah really and so they gave it to my
dad in like the first year or second
year
and i got nominated
last year
golden apple did right [ __ ] a
and then they called me and retracted it
oh [ __ ] but i'm gonna tell you why
because they're rules because they're
like old school
thinking rules
and they didn't
come into
[Music]
they didn't think about the fact that
hey there could be a new owner of golden
apple whether bill evo would sold it to
somebody else
or if god for it
bit his stupid kid grew up and wanted to
run it right right
and so i i made this point to the powers
that be
and got him to change the rule
so how does it feel to be a second
generation owner like it means
everything to me because you know that
award when it sits up above the register
of golden apple comics if you've ever
been into our shop it's just cool ass
you know
crystal thing it's awesome
and will eisner hand it to my dad i got
a picture of that it's holy [ __ ] pretty
awesome he was legendary he felt like he
was like his dad it was awesome and um
but it says
it's to bill leibowitz and then in
parentheses golden apple right it was it
was given to the person
with the accomplishment not the store
name and so that was my my deciding
point and so
it's not that i want to win an award i
don't even know if i deserve an award
but
the point was there are other owners i
mean i know some stores in la that
they've had four or five new owners that
are not family related why shouldn't
they win an award if they're doing a
better job or or whatnot so there's some
some great shops out there that have new
owners it's like an old diner where the
old guy you know ran it for 50 years and
then retired and sold it to some other
and they
they should get an award right so it
means everything i mean i go into that
store every day and it's like seeing my
dad like he yeah his picture's on the
wall but like
i know he's
proud like not to get all deep into it
no he's super don't want to bring the
room down but no that brings the room up
man i
i worked pretty hard and you know i've
tried a lot of things i wear a lot of
hats as you i don't physically wear them
i just like you know sort of because you
got a good head of air but you do you're
always very like i did a production
company
about publishing company actually did i
do publishing i've i've done publishing
for several years
way back
that was always a living logo with susie
owens the playmate playmate by day
superhero by now that was right he had
that you guys she was a nurse she was a
nurse
did you publish more than one book or
multiple books
two books from dark horse and no she was
a nurse by day superhero by night
she was actually a playboy playmate when
playboy was still around the kids
actual character and my dad got half
hugh hefner to put a spread
in playboy of susie owens as this
character flacks them for the second
golden apple unbelievable and what year
is that now that was like my dad's
favorite crowning moment that he was in
playboy
would that be
i have to be like late 80s early 90s not
early 90s 1992
long before people gave a [ __ ] about
comic books or something like that oh
yeah i mean he just he was a trailblazer
he was a pioneer in the comic book
industry and part of the the thing that
we're doing here is to just carry on his
legacy right
um and i guess my family's to to that
effect
because the point of this is all i'm not
going to be here forever nor no offense
to you guys neither are you guys oh no i
got plans in the opposite direction i am
going to be here forever i'm a little
nice but i'm a little worried in a
hundred years and a hundred years with
the paper shortages and the covid and
the digital comics and the nfts like is
is comic-con gonna exist is golden apple
gonna exist are comic book stores gonna
still be printed i don't know i hope so
yeah damn well hope so i hope you guys
man
hold on i'm going to share with you
something that kevin told me a couple
years ago
comic-con comic book stores
all of this isn't about
what you're buying and selling it's
about community so it will absolutely
it's the thing this guy gets it it's
like that's you could tell from
this year alone this is the first time
we've been back in three years at all
doing comic con together
i take it for granted because i live in
a world full of this [ __ ] i live in a
pop culture soaked world i go to many
cons and fan expos and stuff like that
but what about the person who's like you
know i'm the lone ghostbuster
in [ __ ] pacoima like nobody else is
into this [ __ ] but me and every [ __ ]
year i go to san diego comic-con and i
find my tribe i find my people i find my
community and that's the thing like i'll
[ __ ] work a shitty job all year long
because those four days that's all i'm
working toward and for three years
that's been like snatched away from a
lot of people that's what i've been
seeing in everybody's face at cons of
ours like people just grateful to be
around other people like-minded
individuals communities really nice
definitely so i mean i'm still going to
con
applause for that absolutely so i'm
still continuing
to sell comic books you know on a retail
level
uh i don't really have a lot of plans to
open like stores around the world or
anything like that i'm pretty content if
you know anything about us we did have
multiple locations i sold those off
because i'm just
one store one family one business like
jerry maguire man
jerry mcguire
so this this foundation is really you
know near and dear to my heart and i i
want to help
this we have a slogan you remember what
is it help save comics that's right yell
it out
help save comics kids
this is a shirt i brought you sorry mark
only board members get shirts i mean
that's fair i get it that's beautiful i
will wear that shirt where can they get
information how can folks at home help
out
you know the best thing you can do is
like you know hear what we have to say
today maybe you watched it on the live
stream and you're at home somewhere
maybe you're here right now
uh you watch it on a replay and you said
wow that's really cool kevin smith's a
board member on this new charity
organization to help save comics
tell somebody else it's you know it's
about spreading the word
and
um
and it's really about
preserving comics and celebrating comics
and the industry as well as the heroes
we had i mean we've lost some major
people
this year you know obviously
george perez neil adams and even a
couple days ago my goodness
um
you know we're here to celebrate those
people remember the legends that were
and show people their art if you've been
to the comic-con museum
which is right over here they just
opened there's all the original art on
the walls go see some original art if
you go into comic con there's all those
boring booths over on the right with
those old comic books all dusty comics
those big oversized pages
go look at those they're amazing you
don't have to buy any of them but like
just appreciate this art form that we do
that's why we're here it's the track
they have the track we have some great
board members mike malvey is here
tonight from atomic comics
over here we got heidi mcdonald marcan
draco's
[Music]
an amazing uh a writer and creator and
of course gary
who's the the collector who started it
all and gave us the collection who which
we're now starting to organize and go
through and you know get it all set so
we can go to the university of
pennsylvania
you know if someone wants to donate we
do have a website coming out we have
social media
um out there you can find us real easy
especially or you could give it to them
right now
or i could give it to you
that one right there yeah it's g apple
caf on on most of the uh
you know the socials uh instagrams go g
apple foundation but even if you just
type in golden apple foundation you will
find us if you find g apple comics or
golden apple we always link
to everything um you know and honest
with each other and thank you for having
me on we love comic books and the big
feature comic books are superheroes uh
you today are a real life one give it up
for ryan everybody
excellent job thank you guys i really
appreciate it enjoy the show
and help save comics
[Applause]
excellent job
uh somebody actually talking about
comics
at comic-con look at that
uh let's talk about you before we get
out of here cause we gotta get out of
here we're not meant to do a very very
long show and it's already almost 5 30.
we just get lost don't we yeah it's so
much fun uh mark is going to leave here
and um he's going over to the eisner
awards where as we previously said uh
he's up for one for adora and the
distance
i paused just for that oh
you guys
um your moments before the inevitable
happens whatever that may be i happen to
think it's going to be the positive how
are you feeling you know i'm uh i i i
choose to anticipate disappointment
which leaves room for surprise
so i won't be upset if we don't win
because we didn't make it the book to
win awards
we just wanted to tell a story that
hopefully some people would respond to i
hope you win because it's good marketing
for our show it classes it up
we'll be able to put like [ __ ]
starring eisner award winner mark
bernard
[Music]
fair enough
i'll win it for you kev featuring kevin
smith like afterwards she'll take the
lead
um the ceremony ever been to it the
eisners i was there once i was a judge a
long while ago and uh and so i went to
the eisners um it's it's always nice to
be in in the company of comic book
legends and comic book
heroes of mine and talented people um
it's a long night though so uh so i'm
gonna strap in i might get myself some
movies grub before i leave oh yeah
that's good idea are you gonna lick her
up you're gonna be drunk for this i'm
gonna try not to be drunk for this
because on the off chance we do win i
gotta go and give a speech and it'll be
amazing if you give a drunk speech at
the eyes [ __ ] everybody
did you prep do you have a little yeah
did you make did you write a speech i
did not write a speech who the [ __ ] am i
yeah
i'm gonna get up there and i'm gonna
punch chris rock in the face
[Laughter]
that'll make the news i know did you
just punch a dude in the face well yeah
that's what you do when you win
um
that's such a good point uh ladies and
gentlemen uh we're gonna wrap up and let
mark go do his thing and soon we're
about to start jane salambob get old
with jason muse however
i know it wasn't planned for a lot of
you a lot of you were just here eating
and suddenly a [ __ ] show happens you
have a good time this evening
[Applause]
we can't thank you enough for being here
man uh but there is no show without the
guy sitting next to me give it up for
marvelous mark bernardin
thank you kay
and that is fat man beyond the update
for today we'll be back tomorrow do we
do it at the same time same fat same
time oh my god we can literally say it
we're gonna be back tomorrow doing at
the same that time and the same fat
channel uh but for now
that's fat man beyond ladies and
gentlemen i'm kevin smith i'm mark
bernardin tune in tomorrow same fat time
same fat channels podcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith jeff's kiss
everybody mwah enjoy comic con
[Applause]
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask if anything every saga has a 10
year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith